you
[Music]
well it's a it's an incredible honor
having you here Peter I feel like cost
industry there's probably no one that's
more like a peer than you are being the
original research director at Google so
it's great to have you visited at
Microsoft Research today what did it is
start with I think if it's such a rich
and interesting career to date and much
more to come but you take your undergrad
at Brown and applied math and then you
went off to Berkeley what was your
thinking about what you wanted to do
back then and why did you choose that
grad school and path yeah so I was an
applied math major as an undergrad
because a computer science major didn't
exist there was something like a
computer science program but it you you
couldn't be a major in that also some of
the classes to me felt like to class in
IBM assembly language and so I took the
interesting computer classes then I felt
like gee four years of college that's
enough I don't want to go to grad school
I worked in what we would now call a
startup company for two years after two
years of that I said gee took me two
years to get tired of work maybe I like
school twice as much yeah and I'd live
my whole life in New England and I had
friends who had gone out to California
so I said well that's the thing for me
and so I applied to Stanford in Berkeley
and both schools unanimously agreed I
should go to Berkeley so that's where I
ended up I was interested in in AI and
in particular natural language I knew
about Polanski was there what was your
like what got you interested in that
though what was the background on that I
think maybe it goes back to high school
and I was lucky enough to be in a high
school that had both the computer class
you know we were on a teletype connected
to a PDP one or something like that in
basic and we also had a linguistics
class and so I took those two classes
and I said to my teacher
you know maybe these two are related
this linguistic stuff seems like there's
formal language there and the computer
stuff seems like that can make it work
and my teacher very wisely says yeah yes
there's something there but you don't
know enough to do it yet and you dove
into into understanding stories with Bob
and yeah how did that evolve what was
your experience with that so you know I
started out by saying well there's this
there's the stuff we can do in
linguistics to understand sentences but
really the interesting thing about
language is what does it mean not just
out of the sentences work and we're
still worrying about that today we're
still worrying about that right and so
you know as we're reading a story what's
left unsaid can be answer questions
about the story and so I worked on that
and I I guess my main experience was
saying this is too hard to do by hand
and the way we did things back then who
was by introspection and you wrote out
by hand statements and a knowledge
representation language and you wrote
inference rules and then you tried it
and you know you do like one paragraph a
month and then you'd get that working
but then they would have broken half of
the things you had before and so you
know I managed to stumble across the
finish line and get a thesis done but it
was clear that this writing out
knowledge by hand just was not scalable
and I thought there were two problems
one what was we we tried to have the
representation language basically be
logical and you know as I was finishing
up I was just beginning to come around
to the probabilistic side and and you
and Ackerman were part of that Pete
reeseman was part of that and I think
mostly you day at Pearl I remember
sitting in a lecture the the moment that
he converted me and I said aha he's got
the right idea and and this is the way
we're gonna have to go and that's gonna
give us a lot more flexibility and then
the second part was shifting from this
handcrafted knowledge representation to
machine learning to say let's learn from
examples rather than trying to do it all
by ourselves and
they're everything got it got easier and
we got to the point where instead of
doing a paragraph at a time we're doing
billions of pages at a time and before
we get to that that current current
state of affairs so you did a number of
things but then I recall we've been very
slightly into the community at Peter
Norvig was now at NASA and what
motivated that that role and and you're
going to NASA will you a spaceman over
the years or yeah so it's interesting
and I know you've spent some time and
involved as well as actually a NASA NASA
Ames Research Center graduate fellow the
funded might be work so I I just thought
it was really cool and I think and my
time there you saw there was two types
of people right so there were some who
wanted to be an astronaut since they
were three years old and couldn't think
of working anywhere else but NASA and
then there were some who just said this
is a really cool application of the
computer science that I'm doing and I
could be here or I could be an another
place that had another type of Google
app and during that era there was a lot
of interest I remember in an automated
scientist how can we make new Hunton you
know develop new kinds of autonomy for
space yeah so you know is that the sort
of the infancy of the robotics industry
and space was one of the places where it
was cost-effective you need a robot
pretty badly you need a robot really
badly and you can save many many
millions or hundreds of millions of
dollars by sending a robot rather than a
person because the person doesn't need a
return ticket among other reasons and so
it was a great application for that it
was a it was also a turning point in my
career because it was really the first
time that I went from being an
individual contributor or managing a
small group to managing a big group I
think you were like at one point in time
the chief scientist at NASA for more
computer science me yeah that's great
and so so anything particularly pop out
as being remarkable a remarkable memory
from your NASA days I mean I guess
I guess one cool memory I had was being
at waiting for a shuttle launch it ended
up not going off but just sitting there
with some of the old-timers and and
hearing what they had to say and Bob
savely was there he was the navigator on
Apollo 13 so it was his job when the
power went out in the capsule he had to
say how are we going to get home and
they have fiducial marks in the windows
so he calculated lineup this mark with
that star and this other mark with that
other star and fire the Rockets for two
and a half second you'll get and if I'm
wrong you die okay let's say like look
at home like that one better so so now I
know these days with with the rise of
interesting capabilities in AI there's
lots of interest in safety and
robustness and just going back to your
NASA days there were two failures I
think on your watch them were quite
newsworthy not at the level of Apollo 13
for the stakes but but still interesting
and with messages for us and I you wrote
about one of them quite extensively yeah
that's right so when I was there Dan
Goldin was the administrator he had this
motto faster better cheaper which meant
when you screw up you only lost a
hundred million dollars rather than a
billion dollars and people write and
know people so the planets line up every
two years or so and there's an
opportunity to launch so we launched two
in 98 they both failed to Mars to Mars
sorry and one of them was famous it was
this metric versus English conversion
and my conclusion there was really an
issue of software reuse because we took
the code that had run from the previous
mission and reused it but in the
previous mission it was just telemetry
data that was non critical to navigation
in any way so it wasn't really reviewed
but in this new mission it became it was
sort of
went into the side and became part of
the path the critical path into
navigation and so nobody really
remembered that it was important then
that they should check it out and some
intern uses the wrong units and you know
when you're going to Mars if you're
99.999% accurate that's not enough right
you need that last couple of miles out
somehow
meters to feet doesn't seem like a point
zero zero zero nine problems seems
bigger no but good but what it was is it
was measuring the solar wind on the
panels and how much that would shift and
I see a spaceship so that's a really
teeny amount that coverage is enough to
screw it up and then the other ones a
Mars Polar Lander so I think so I think
the thing there is we should have better
models of reality and embrace and
certainty rather than try to get rid
what happened with that one we think
we're not 100% sure but we think what
happened is the spaceship comes in and
there's three phases of control for how
you land so one there's a burn and then
you're completely out of contact as it
goes around the planet so it's just
decelerating then you start to get into
the Martian atmosphere and you're coming
down under a parachute not much
atmosphere there so the parachute
doesn't slow you that much and then and
there's a radar detecting how far you
are above the ground and when you get to
I think it was something like 20 meters
I forget the exact number the radar
becomes unreliable because things are
bouncing and so then you just look for
the touchdown sensors and so the ship
has legs on it and there's sort of a
collar there which is a Hall effect
sensor and when it hits the ground the
leg punches up goes past the sensor and
you cut off the engine because you've
hit ground and what they didn't realize
because it's hard to test in in zero
gravity is that when the legs first
unfolded they bounced and set off that
sensor
and so what happened is you got down to
20 meters you said okay now I'm gonna
shift from paying attention to the radar
to pay attention to the sensor and the
middle a second later they made that
shift and they said oh well sensors
already going off so now I'm gonna turn
off the engines and from a software
engineering point of view if you think
of deterministic software this is a
pretty good design because we know that
the the more complex the interface
between two systems the more chances
they are to screw it up so if you have a
small interface between two systems
that's a good software design but if
you're trying to model the real world
where there's uncertainty then you don't
want a small interface you want to pass
as much information as possible right so
the the radar phase should have told the
touchdown phase I think I'm at 20 meters
and if the touchdown phase says I'm at
zero meters a millisecond later he said
no that can't happen
calling alert calling Thomas Bayes to
the rescue too late though we didn't
have it then and and I think over time
we're getting better and the other thing
that that came out of this is so I was
on these review boards we go to these
meetings and it's Lockheed and JPL and
on the one hand they're very
scientifically trying to get to the
bottom of what went wrong on the other
hand they're kind of subtly trying to
blame the other guy and so I'm sitting
in these all day PowerPoint
presentations and one day in the morning
break I noticed that Bob sack I'm
doesn't come back he's a long time a
veteran and at one point every landing
on a foreign body that had been
successful he had worked on and everyone
that had failed he had not worked on
mooses bone
he's a propulsion engineer so he doesn't
come back to the to the panel and you
know later in the day he still didn't
come back finally he comes back and said
Bob where'd you go and he said these
PowerPoint presentations were going
nowhere I went down the hall found one
of my old buddies we went over it now I
understand what's going on and you don't
see
so I went back to my hotel that night
it's thinking about you know is
powerpoint really the problem and that's
when I wrote the Gettysburg PowerPoint
presentation about that Gettysburg
PowerPoint presentation so I just had
this idea that sometimes these
presentation tools stop you from getting
to where you want to go rather than then
help you and so I wanted to have an
example of that and I thought of the
great speeches in history and I took
Lincoln's Gettysburg and turned it into
a PowerPoint presentation and I you know
you had what's it called the wizard or
something and I thought I gotta have to
work really hard to make this
presentation look really bad and I have
to choose some terrible colors and so on
and and fortunately the wizard kind of
did it all for it made it really bad
without me even really trying to heart
to try it on me feel good as a Microsoft
person might not be I think it's much
better now okay but at that point in 98
it was easy to make a really bad
presentation you've had the office
assistant helping you back then he was
right but and and you hear stories of
like when Lou Gerstner took over at IBM
they started giving him presentations
and he just went over and turned off the
machine and just said tell me about your
business let's have a conversation and I
think that's the way to do it so I
remember being surprised when I heard
that you went off to Google a smallish
startup and I even remember sitting at a
triple AI fellows dinner and we will you
had a bunch of questions about search
and B where answered trying to answer
them together though coming to the fore
for you at the your day job and what was
that like and why did you make that leap
to Google back then oh yeah was that by
the way so that was 2001 and one of the
reasons was I had been at NASA for three
years three years of government
bureaucracy starts to wear you down we
had recently had a presidential election
took a little bit longer than normal to
decide who won but even before it was
decided both candidates had said they
were going to replace the NASA
administrator so I thought you know
there's gonna be a year at NASA when
nothing happens just so if you're gonna
leave this is the time to leave and then
I started to look around and think about
it and I guess we didn't quite have the
word Big Data then but I knew that's
what I wanted to do and I knew Google
with the place that seemed to be on on
the top of that what's it like in the in
the days when you show it up there
there's a lot of fun
when I joined a company was three years
old and 200 people and so it was just
sort of everybody pitches in and we're
always behind and you try to get stuff
done and we have all these resources we
have these great colleagues and you say
I have an idea let's try it out and see
what works if you look at where things
are now with Google coming - even - into
existence in the in the late 90s and
where it is now it seems rather shocking
and surprising and you probably would be
surprised yourself sure if you could
just jump to 2020 and look back yeah
yeah well certainly you know maybe you
were surprised when you heard I was
going other people said are you crazy
you're giving up a job for this startup
company it could go under and then I
said well one you know they shared some
stuff with me and I don't think it's
gonna go under so so that was right I
didn't have any idea that it would
succeed when that was before he even had
the ad system running correct so they
they were just putting it in that
remember the question people said well
Google's everywhere everyone's using it
but what's your what's your model and
they said were a bit that later right
which was fabulous right so they they
just put the system in and and there
were numbers that were going up into the
right and it's hard to predict the
future but it looked pretty strong right
then and and a lot of people hadn't
really realized how strong that
potential was now I actually came on
board as a title of director of machine
learning because I told them you know I
think machine learning could be
important at this company someday but
after a couple months there we realized
two things one was that maybe there
shouldn't be a separate Department of
machine learning that should be
integrated every
and secondly that they needed to refocus
on search because they had taken a lot
of the top people off the search team
and put them on ads to build the the ad
system and taken the foot off the gas on
search and so then I moved over to to be
the manager at the Search Group for for
five or six years it's been interesting
to watch the investments and even
comments even years ago by Google's
leadership I think one comment was Larry
or Sergey said we're a company we just
don't realize it yet something along
those lines and to see how central AI is
now yeah right so I think he was way out
in front of that sundar has lately been
saying we're AI first a a couple years
ago we were mobile first I liked the AI
first might have better first of all
because it's my field but secondly
because mobile first was kind of a
reaction it was saying you know what
we're behind the world is shifting off
of desktops into mobile and you know
whatsapp and all these other guys
they're ahead of us there so we have to
catch up in mobile and and that was a
good leadership to remind the company
because otherwise we would have fallen
farther behind and I think we did
eventually catch on to that but the AI
first is more of it's not that we're
behind is that there's a great
opportunity here to move ahead
now speaking of AI you and I are
relatively have traveled through the
same AI worlds over time from the
theorem proving and logic centric AI
into the probabilistic reasoning and
then we've seen this recent upswing back
to connectionism where we see the rise
of the power for perception sexual tasks
of neural nets deep networks in
particular I'm curious to get your sense
for things when I was talk to you before
about this even in front of in front of
senators and these panels but you share
your sense for for the where we are now
in a history of AI and what this means
moving forward
these recent discoveries and and in
capabilities we have yeah still trying
to get my my hand around it so I did
make this shift from logical to
probabilistic along with with a lot of
the other of the field at varying speeds
and and it's hard to give up on that
right because you you see the benefits
of having that kind of a worldview and
so for a long time I was trying to say
well these deep networks they must be
probabilistic models or something we
just don't know what their models are
that's I see what I think too and and
that that's got to be true in some sense
but but only in kind of a total aaja
chol sense that anything can be can be
viewed as a probabilistic model and and
I'm not quite sure that that's the most
useful way of looking at it right so
instead now I think you get more of
these are just optimization machines and
you tell it what you want and they get
you there and it's a very bumpy
multi-dimensional surface so you might
not get quite up to the top but you get
close and so I think now to me one thing
that's really shifted about the way I
see a AI is like you know I'm been
working now on on revising the AI
textbook and in the previous editions we
said okay we're gonna define a is
maximizing expected utility so you tell
these important probabilities important
here's all these cool algorithms that
can help you and you give me a utility
function and I'll optimize it for you
but now we're saying well we got all
these algorithms and they're great so
maybe the optimization is the easy part
but knowing what the utility function
should be that's the hard part
and so now we have all this fairness and
accessibility and privacy and so on and
it's deciding what it is that you should
want that's harder than figuring out how
to optimize getting there testing
because that's always been a concern but
it's been largely as a probably will
remain outside of the technical field
it's one of aligning values
understanding human preferences better
you could imagine tools and learn
algorithms that could help people with
that help with that task as well not a
part of the technology thoughts about
that yeah yeah I think that's right I
think I think we need those kinds of
tools and I've been thinking about
trying to broaden the scope of our tools
right so you know we have our tensor
flow tool and and there's other
competing tools but they're really just
a small part of the pipeline of saying I
prepared my data here now I'm going to
optimize my parameters and my output
comes here but feeding into that is
where did the data come from how do you
manage it how do you update it and then
feeding out of it is how do you turn
this into a product and and serve that
product and maintain it over time and so
on and that whole pipeline is hard but
we only give you a lot of help for the
little optimization step in the middle
and I'd like to see more of a focus on
the lifetime or the whole pipeline
learning lifecycle with the rise of
capabilities at AI and the rise of
interest both among experts and beyond
civil society academic organizations
studying different disciplines whether
it be social science and philosophy it's
interesting to to to see the growing
interest and to even see at our
companies like a Microsoft we have an
ether committee process working groups
deliberating about sensitive uses of AI
for example in engineering best
practices what's happening at Google in
this space yeah that's a great issue so
we published our set of AI principles we
spent a lot of time internally going
over that saying what are some
guidelines for what we want to do and
what we don't want to do were involved
with a couple different types of
partnerships we
of external review boards and we have
internal discussions of what we should
be doing and not doing and I think you
know the world becomes more complicated
right it wasn't that hard to say we want
to provide access to all the world's
information and so if there's a web page
you should be able to find it that was
more or less neutral and there were
definitely some political issues
involved and now you make mistakes with
that but those are easier kind of
problems to deal with and now the
problems we're dealing today should you
be working with the military should you
be exporting surveillance technology and
so on and so we want to we're definitely
taking a let's go slow some things we're
ruling out altogether and other things
we're saying were saying let's be
careful as we as we think and go ahead
that's fabulous
what are your thoughts about where AI is
in 2050 just to speculate analogies it's
hard to predict especially the future I
think we'll see more in our everyday
lives I think you'll see more kind of
personalization both in terms of what
you carry with you you know so now a lot
of people have phones you're wearing a
watch there'll be lots of prosthetic
devices that would that will help you
out and do things and maybe they'll be
connected with rest of the world in a
much deeper way
I think they'll also be backlashes
against that of people saying the way to
be really advanced is to just completely
disconnect and go off the grid and so I
think you mean yeah you'll see some some
splits there I'm really interested in
the robotics industry you know I've been
thinking for a while eventually it's
gonna take off and it's kind of
disappointed me and how slow it's going
you know if you think back to the
personal computer industry and
I'm saying the seventies you could buy a
computer and it was pretty expensive and
it really couldn't do very much that was
useful but it was fun to play with but
then within a decade you know everybody
had one in their home and at some point
that transition will happen with
robotics but it didn't happen last
decade and I don't know if it's gonna
happen this one or if it's gonna be I
mean definitely by by 2050 it will have
happened probably it's gonna happen in
more in the industrial settings first
which are more controlled environments
and also like NASA they can afford to
pay more for them so we'll see advances
first there and then they'll start to
trickle down into the home and everybody
what are your thoughts on making some
fundamental progress on what I like to
refer to as the long term standing
mysteries of human intellects which I've
barely scratched the surface of with all
the fanfare about AI yeah difficult
we'll make some good progress there or
are we making progress more than we even
know potentially I think we will I like
to keep these ideas separate right and
this was also one of the criticisms I
had of the work that was going on back
like when I was in grad school right so
I came out of this tradition that was
kind of a mix of AI and cognitive
science and it always seems like an
excuse where you would say well your
program doesn't perform very well here
and you'd say oh yeah but it's
cognitively plausible and then you'd say
but your program does things that a
brain couldn't possibly do yeah but I
get better performance that way right
and so if you're aiming for these two
peaks of scientific understanding of the
brain and best performance usually end
up in the valley in between when you say
what I say myth you do know like I mean
our ability to learn so well without the
way our ability to manage massive
quantities and learn things common sense
ability to transfer tasks quickly and
easily I mean I don't need to go to
flapping wings and human-like things but
even really scratching the surface of
the capabilities I'm getting at in some
ways yeah so we want to understand that
we want to understand why are humans so
good at what they do why are they bad at
what they don't do
again we interface with them better
right I mean I think we we all want to
be able to have a conversation with our
computers rather than having to program
them in the slow way we do and in order
to do that they're gonna have to
understand us and we're and we're gonna
have to understand that and I think you
know eventually we'll get to that better
understanding I think some of it will
come through AI some of it will come
through neuroscience and we'll get
improvements but it's hard to predict
how long it's gonna take so how to do
these advances in AI we're seeing right
now with learning from massive
quantities of data and even now having
available streams of data from our
applications how is this gonna get the
get effects software engineering and
software maintenance in the future yeah
so that's a great topic and and I think
things are changing part of it has to do
with techniques we use and part of it
has to do with the problems we try to
address right so there's problems we can
we can attack now that we could never
attack before right sorry so I remember
the Google Photos team coming to me and
saying you've got a bunch of user
experience experts on your team and we
need some help helping people organize
photos into folders because they have
too many full photos and they're getting
confused can you design a better user
interface for it
and I said yes we do have some of those
experts and they're great and they could
probably do that but over here we've got
these computer vision people and they
can probably organize the things
automatically without you having to do
anything they said I didn't know you
were allowed to ask for that yeah and so
I think we'll see a lot of these kinds
of things where you know sort of normal
software design
we'll say well I was gonna do it the
hard way but here's this magic way that
can do something that I could never do
before
and so that'll be part of software and
that will change things and then the
other part is just improving kind of
regular software right so like Dave
Patterson's been working with us on like
well how do you build an operating
system well one of the things you do is
you do some experiments and say well I
think the page size should be
such-and-such when running on this kind
of machine and then you make that choice
and you hard coded into your program
right but then you get a different
computer or your your mix of programs
changes and now it's the wrong choice
right so we're looking at can all these
parameters be optimized through machine
learning and it's still you know humans
still writing most of the code but then
a lot of these choices get done better
and can be updated continuously then I
think software testing changes a lot and
I think it's already changing right so
it used to be and you know you guys at
Microsoft's were the kings of this that
once a year you put a disk into a box
and you put it in trucks and they were
delivered to stores and then people pay
money for him and brought him home and
that meant you had a release cycle that
said there is all these tests we're
gonna run and it's gonna be a pain but
when we get it done there's a golden
disc right and we're not gonna touch it
for a long time but then as we started
to move into the cloud and into the data
centers it was more like we're not gonna
ship once a year we're gonna ship every
day and so that changed the testing
cycle and you were making lots of small
changes rather than big changes and then
then the third step was when machine
learning came in and now you say well
now I can have an online process and
that's kind of scary because now you no
longer have time to run all your tests
every millisecond as you're updating
your model with live data and it's more
like a control theory problem rather
than
a logical testing problem where you say
I want my system to maintain within some
envelope and I want some kind of
guarantees or if not guarantees at least
some assurances that it's gonna remain
there but I'll have some monitors to say
if it starts getting out of bounds then
somebody better look at it
and we better do something about it
that's a really change it's changes the
way you think about what testing is how
frequently it's done and what you have
to look for so you can see the whole
field and even education about software
development methodology changing over
time yeah yeah and and I also think it's
important to distinguish between the
problem and the solution right so people
criticize machine learning models saying
well how can you really trust them
because the answer could be anything and
to some extent that's true that there is
uncertainty in what in what you get but
some of that comes from the technique
using machine learning and some of it
just comes from the problem itself right
so if I you know if I ask you to sort a
list of numbers there's a definitive
correct answer and we can test for that
and prove it correct but if I say here's
a web query sort the list of web pages
that are relevant to that query there is
no one definitive answer so they are the
uncertainty used in the problem
definition and whether you're using
machine learning or whether you're using
traditional programming that uncertainty
is still going to be there you you
exemplify somebody who is follow their
interests and had such a fabulous career
still deep progress magically finding
these interesting roles over time where
you've prospered intellectually and
socially in all ways and you've mentored
as you've gone with your writings and
and and work with with with
collaborators young people and peers and
others and curation if you have some
advice to to young folks out there about
about career any any mottos or insights
you could share
well so one is you know I just feel like
I'm lucky to be at a time when the kinds
of thing is that we know how to do or
things that were wanted and there were
there were lots of opportunities because
the field was growing and so you know
it's like the there weren't all that
many bad choices but I also think that
you should follow what you think is
right what you think matches what you
can do so I haven't been in multiple
places I've had all the top-level
domains
edu dot-com and a little bit of gov and
you know in grad school at that time I
felt like you were brainwashed into
saying you really should be a professor
that's the ultimate goal now it's much
more fluid people go back and forth but
that was the idea that and yet I gave it
all up
and I think the reason I gave it up is
because I felt like what was expected
from you as a professor was not that
well aligned with what I wanted to do so
yes I enjoyed teaching I enjoyed
creating educational materials and books
and so on and you got a little bit of
credit for that but not that much and I
was ok at writing research papers and
that's really the thing that they
focused on and I didn't want to focus
exclusively on that and I really enjoyed
programming and that was another thing
that was not that well rewarded in the
academic profession so I said well it
looks like industry is a better match
because because the things I want to do
is the things that they reward better
and so I think you know kind of follow
the path to what makes sense for you
where you want it where are you your
skills match up with what's needed I
have to ask you just folks that don't
know you well might think you put on a
special shirt for me today for this the
history of and and the backgrounds on
these incredible shirts that I always
see you in yeah so ironically part of it
again goes back to NASA ok is there a
planet there
this particular shirt but you know I go
to my job at NASA and actually one of
the things I asked them in the interview
process was do I have to wear a tie and
they said when you go to headquarters
yes but when you're at Ames no so I said
okay I can handle that
you know we're business casual and so I
do that and then my first Friday on the
job they say no not business casual
today today's dress down Friday you have
to wear a lion shirt I like that demand
okay I'll start exploring that so I did
that and I've had an answer for a while
and then I guess the real turning point
was my wife's handy with with sewing and
she had made like Halloween costumes for
the kids and stuff and at one point they
said how come you never make anything
for daddy and so she found this great
fabric which is a print of classic 1950s
tin toy toy robots and made a shirt out
of that for me and so that was a great
shirt and I remember one day we were
doing a photo shoot at Google I think
was for Fast Company and you know they'd
already done Larry and Sergey so this
was like the next level down where they
were in their black turtlenecks yeah
yeah right so you know this with me and
Susan Wojcicki energy or something like
that and they said okay come in and you
know we have to take some head shots and
it's gonna be like four people on a page
and I show up wearing the robot shirt
and they say oh you get a full page from
then on I said you know I can train from
examples and you get a reward function
so okay my trademark fabulous it's a
great favor Mart
thanks very much Peter yeah